what's the most insanely romantic thing
that someone has ever done for each of
you I just had somebody send me some
cookies too because I've been working in
London
but the cookies got held up in customs
they kind of arrived mouldy yeah this is
the opposite of the square they sure
maybe the thought the thought was
excellent she heard all the stories like
that I was once gifted cupcakes by this
girl who was a very big fan and she put
she gave me the cupcakes and I ate the
cupcake a strand of her hair was a baked
inside the cupcake which might or might
not have been on purpose which ya know
it was like a chunk it wasn't like a lot
it was like a lock of her hair so I
don't know what kind of voodoo magic she
was me but if you're out there I love
you and I would like to find romantic
stuff happened I mean I have been
blessed in that I was just telling a
little story about like right on the day
of our wedding the sweetest thing that
the night before naked done was I walked
into my room with my bridesmaids to do
this like last night and our separation
and whatever and the entire room was lit
up and they were like flowers everywhere
making a pathway to the bedroom and
little gifts which had notes attached
them with his promises to me I will
always keep you safe I will always
protect you I'll always respect to you
ever and like everyone was and expounded
on that I'm not just one and it was just
like so mind-blowing I think all my
bridesmaids were just so depressed yeah
I mean it is a big nose
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the movie is just so much fun and a
rebel I feel like it's your baby I don't
you're starring in a produces felt like
such an accomplishment for you um oh it
has and you know for those who work
behind the scenes in movies they know it
takes years to get a big big movie to
the screen and yeah I'm so proud of it
I'm so proud of like the amazing cars we
have and the crew he just did an awesome
job and I can't wait to unleash it on
everyone and we really hope you like it
it's really for everyone on this
Valentine's Day you don't love me
Natalie's saying that romantic comedies
are about all those movies our lives
it's a terrible pop songs I have to ask
you too though is it in your contracts
at this point that you only sing and
dance together continue to being movies
together you know because the audience
demands the world is clamoring for
Priyanka you're integral we saw this
picture on Instagram you're stretching
rebel out before the dance yeah where it
was that part of your job description as
well that was the part of my job to do
sir you know that's what you guys are
doing these big musical numbers on the
streets of New York why we shot in the
semi in New York City where anyone who's
in the amount of powder that they used
on us specifically I would just like to
soften their shirts yeah well and every
sexy there was more sexy when Liam was
doing it but my best yeah yeah I just
told me though that Liam didn't really
love the dancing did you guys actually
like Liam I know was scared about it but
then like when you saw him doing it you
could tell he was he's like yeah yeah
he practiced he practice when he went
back what every night which I was like I
was thinking when we were going to do it
I was like I've wondered like Miley like
showed him a few moves because she
doesn't much of that stuff and like she
didn't he didn't he'd really got into it
you know he had such a great time the CD
was right next to mean he was like fully
into it um he really makes yeah in this
movement Priyanka I wondered with you
two were like that rehearsing thing I
mean obviously if so much experience
yourself but your husband's a
professional singer did he run your
numbers with you did you rehearse I
don't even know of them I mean I knew
yeah and like we texted but didn't exist
in that realm at that Wow
in fact we had so many single
conversation yeah I know we were like
talking about men and well is it true
that you've requested to be part of a
throuple with Miley and Liam on
downloads no Miley often good was a
trouble it's like okay I've been invited
to yet to join Miley and Liam
I think only because I posted a sad
Instagram post which said that I've
never ever had a date on Valentine's Day
which is totally true I've had dates
don't get me wrong but never on
Valentine's Day so she invited me to be
with them but I feel like it'll be weird
okay you know it might be yeah yeah
they've been together a long time though
they many and if they've invited you a
VIP
yeah yes I said oh maybe it turns to a
musical number
I think an Instagram to rebel you said
like this is the most loved up cast ever
I knew the guys in the cast to my height
most high profile marriages in the last
12 months
miss Priyanka and Liam I mean that's
what happens when you do realize that's
what happens you get bands that love
juicy yeah love is in the air with this
baby and I think if you guys go and see
this may be love is probably gonna
happen for you from I was the group text
blowing up with congrats because you get
married Liam gets married or are you
guys just like wow congratulations and a
bunch of love in there yeah I mean a lot
of just projecting positivity I don't
know what it was but I just remember a
lot of gifts from Todd is that the gift
came well you and Liam also it's kind of
funny I mean have both married these
former Disney stars were you guys
Montana
oh yeah definitely like when Jonas
Brothers first came out the first time I
made Nick was my girlfriend did a movie
with him Camp Rock too was her love
interest and he sang he like cream the
love with this Shasta super so I
immediately I was like who's this Nick
guy well is he gonna be at the premiere
they've got to say hi at the premiere
like have you and Liam talks just
newlywed life at all and yet I mean just
besides like a [ __ ] relations and
like good luck and everything we haven't
met I mean he's unwell today I was under
some emergencies he makes it at the
premiere or something